how's it gonna I'm I'm been as I said a
pleasure to come talk to you today about
some of the stuff I've been doing in
urban planning and data and government
and things like that really short I
guess I would call myself a Danish
storyteller and what does that mean well
if you ask me a little while ago what a
data storyteller was like a year and a
half ago I really don't know but what's
happened is I've worked for a investment
management firm called 2 Sigma we look
at data and we try to predict the future
sort of where markets go and and through
my skills I've learned there become this
data storyteller thing and so you know
as I said I've got this one career and
on the other hand I married this urban
planner my wife Leslie and she brought
me into this world of urban planning she
went into the statistics class at pratt
but the class wasn't that exciting you
know statistics classes of generally not
and she come up why do I have to learn
this and I and I fine listening in this
and I said you know this is silly we
have all this new york city data coming
out like in real time all over the wall
this data why we teaching students from
a textbook of made-up problems when we
can have them study their own city so I
went to Pratt and I said hey I'd love to
I'd love to sort of run the statistics
class can I can I have a go teaching it
and it started doing that but there's
something that happened before that made
this all possible and that's in New York
City we have the open data loss all
right Bloomberg in 2012 signed
legislation that required city agencies
to release data instead of just give us
like plots and charts and graphs and
figures and infographics so they used to
do now they give us access to the
underlying data below all these charts
and plots when Mayor Bloomberg put this
out he said look across city agencies
are using more and more data to develop
policies implement programs and track
performance each month our
administration shares more and more of
this data with the public at large
catalyze make creativity intellect an
enterprising spirit of computer
programmers to build tools to help us
all improve our lives this is the 2012
bloomberg view of open data and sure
enough the city is investing in these
big app competitions because what is
more data than apps right app app app
app and the city keeps pouring money and
the big apps competition and it's a
great it's really cool there's really
cool app to come out of it but it kind
of misses the point of open data so much
so if you look at what he said he said
look open eight us about computer
programmers and I'm like no no it's not
enough computer programmers
much bigger than that it's about all of
us it's about urban planners it's about
you know policymakers nonprofits anyone
and as their tools get better we'll
actually have access to use this data to
tell the stories that we all want to do
so I where the city kind of thought it
was open data goes to apps and then apps
goes to the world I think it's much more
direct input into all this data and
we're starting to see more and more of
that today the open data portal looks
like this you go to it and it's you know
not very exciting but underneath are
1,200 data sets in new york city the
state runs a portal the federal
government has of course data gov cities
a dozens and dozens dozens of cities the
United States all starting to get on
board and this is something called the
open data census if you want to play go
to the open data census you can google
it type in your city you'll see a list
and ranked list of cities across the
world and then up and down or the city's
left and right are types of data and
they tell you is it downloadable is it
in raw format or is it on a silly map
that you can't analyze and things like
that so before in the old world the taxi
Limousine Commission New York would put
out plots like this how many for hire
vehicles we have how many taxis do we
have and that's what then you know
somebody somewhere ransom query and
they've walk and put out this plot on to
be on the cover of you know NYC gov and
we'd all go home happy but the thing is
there's so many more questions we can
ask about taxis than how many we have
and how can the city know how many
questions we all have right we have
infinite numbers of questions with open
data let's ask your own questions I was
curious when is rush hour in New York
City and luckily all the cabs have GPS
recorder so they drive around and record
their speed you know the time they
picked up a passenger trying to adopt
off pass or how long it took distance
equals rate times time you get average
speed so I plotted the average speed of
New York City cabs to try to investigate
when rush hour is in New York City I
found that a 5 a team in the morning
they're at their fastest speed they're
going 24 miles an hour and then things
go south very quickly down to 11 a half
miles an hour of 8 30 and it turns out
there's no rush hour in New York there's
just a rush day it stays 6 it stays at
11 half miles an hour the entire day but
I couldn't only ask this because it
opened data right technically this is
foiled data someone had to require put
out a Freedom of Information Law
requests another talk for another day
last week new york city under a lot of
pressure over the last including a talk
on this and put out for the first time
trip level data themselves so instead of
having us all foil data over and over
and over again have a poor guy the
agency copy they have you bring a hard
drive
every day it was crazy they finally
posted it last week so we're making
inroads so what happens when we take
data science would have been planning
well I taught this class the thing from
a class or fund so I made this blog
started writing the blog one of the
first things I did was made this map
this is a map of cyclist collisions in
New York City this is where cyclists are
getting into accidents you know it's
pretty there's all this red area I don't
by the way I'm not a designer my maps or
amp but I do my best I think this is
through program called QGIS which is a
spatial software for planners they all
know GIS software I really went to like
file save as heat map like that was it
wasn't really analysis so to say but I
didn't stop it from interesting people
right I put this on the web it was me
learning how to use qjs and suddenly and
by the way williamsburg and roosevelt
avenue and queens these are all hot
spots that we learned from from this and
when i put on the web to see what
happens things started covering it right
gothamist which covers kind of all sorts
of things wrote about this and then it
suddenly was on someone said that I
pegged a Broadway stretch of Bloomberg
as a death trap was like whoa whoa whoa
another article that said killings Berg
like Wellington the New York Post called
it a study I was like it's not a study
at the blog post things got kind of out
of control and it was in the Atlantic
and I'm sitting there going wire this is
I didn't I went to file save as why are
things going what is going on here
there's such a hunger for data why are
people following these data posts so I
realize there's a third leg to all this
stuff it wasn't just the urban planning
in the data science it was really a
third thing I do which is improv an
improv comedy why do I say that because
storytelling is so important in data
science our science curriculum the
United States we don't really do yes you
know we don't cover story tongue we
don't really do communication but if you
can only talk to other scientists about
what you do right if your data blog is
all about data on the Python and the
pearl on the stuff that you downloaded
no one cares except for people like us
but if you can communicate with the
public your message gets farther out so
I started to say well what does improv
comedy have in common with data science
and how can i leverage and that's why I
call it data storytelling because there
are these keys the storytelling with
data so one I love to connect with
people's experiences right I could write
about something random or i could write
about what people in New York I thought
think about so I'm walking around New
York and has a lot of starbucks here and
then I was like I wonder who lives far
this from a starbucks in New York City
so I made this map of New York which is
just a the disk the starbucks distance i
found out that half of New York was
isn't within
blocks of Manhattan excuse me was in
three box of a Starbucks which is pretty
phenomenal but I also found the person
who lived far this from a starbucks in
inwood up up in the little star in the
North kind of useless some things are
more more useful though so in New York
we have this problem during rush hour
the evening rush where taxis all
disappear during the evening rush which
is kind of silly right why because it
turns out that if you if you plot by the
way the income the dollars made per
minute of the entire New York City Taxi
flea you got a plot that looks like this
throughout the day see that big dip
there that is the fetid around four to
five pm so suddenly during rush hour new
york city taxes make all this less money
it's really crazy it's been confounding
new york city for decades ed koch the
mayor was complaining about this this is
just a known problem why because New
York City's has has two shifts for every
legislator that has two shifts for every
cab okay and guess when the optimal time
for me to hand in over the keys to the
other person is so that we both make
equal amounts of money right there's
only one time in the day where a 12-hour
shift previous 12 hours is equal to the
sum of the next 12 hours and that
happens to fall right around a rush hour
in the evening now this is not globally
optimal write the entire fleet would
make more money if we switched it to
p.m. but then the late person was going
to get more money and that would be
unfair it's kind of a game theory
problem so if I plotted actually the
rolling 12-hour amount of money the
fleet was making and where they crossed
means the previous 12 hour shift and
begging the same is an extra hour shift
and sure enough right during the evening
rush hour and putting stuff in fact the
city put a rush hour surcharge trying to
fix this they said let's throw more
money at it we're going to add more
money at rush hour in the evening supply
and demand we're good right the problem
is all that money went to the latest
driver and early drivers like this is
ridiculous why do you get morning I want
more money let's hand it over later in
the day and so the entire equilibrium
point actually shifts later in the rush
hour causing even more problems which I
don't think the city saw coming but some
simple data analysis can kind of help
start to tell these stories so I had the
pleasure when I wrote about this to go
in and speak with the Commissioner of
the taxing Limousine Commission and and
propose an interesting solution which is
the idea that you charge rental fees at
different amounts for each 12 hour shift
so what happens is the the drivers are
renting from a garage and right now the
city has a legislative cap so you can
only charge this much for your cab so if
I want to do an expensive shift in a
cheap shift and have this guy make less
money and this one
our money I can't do that because
legislation has it here so we kind of
legislated ourselves into this mess if
they lift the cap and allow dynamic
pricing we can suddenly make a 12-hour
shift that make less money cost less to
rent make equilibrium then it doesn't
matter when you shift so that hopefully
next year we'll have this problem solved
another thing about data science then
story tongue is not to make things too
complicated so you've heard a lot today
about complex things and actually you
know in my work at two sigma we have all
sorts of interesting predictive models
and machine learning and i have a
background in natural language
processing i get it but there's so much
we can tell just about descriptive and
simple things right and i like to focus
on a single idea when telling a story
and data so here is a map of New York
and I looked at the gender of the city
bike riders our bike share system we can
see male versus female riders and
whether there's a pattern in New York
and that star there is times square and
midtown or all the offices are so what
we're seeing is the riders on bikes in
New York are predominantly I think
eighty to ninety percent male around
midtown Manhattan and only about forty
percent male as we get out to Brooklyn
and this isn't showing cuz the data sets
kind of big and wheel it has all these
things and we're just taking one column
and telling the story of it you can make
visualizations that pop and bam and boom
and do all this stuff and it may be
really cool and artsy but I always try
to define if I look at a visualization
and say what have I learned from this is
there a takeaway and that's how I know
whether I like my visualization or now
um along those lines I like to not just
focus on a single idea but make that
idea relatively simple when possible
right this whole Occam's razor
simplicity has it has its purpose on
people here that you're doing all this
data and they assume there's things
going on like this all the time and I
always like no no no it's it's actually
more like this and it struck me when I
did an analysis and the New York Post
reporter called it how did you do there
but I'm like I counted and they're like
what is your mat I'm like no I counted
because really a lot of the stuff is can
be somewhat simple so I went into New
York and I was curious where tourists go
and I said well how can we look at that
well we can look at parking tickets and
in fact what if we look at the percent
of parking tickets given to non New
Yorkers in every neighborhood right
that's kind of I mean it's not a perfect
indication of choice cuz if not just
tourist but people working and it's a
mixed it's not great but it's a start so
I map the percent in every neighborhood
of tickets given to non New York license
plates and got the
kind of map of New York we're really in
Midtown we have a big bright yellow lots
of people visiting or coming to work
there we see kind of stretches and as we
got farther out from the middle of New
York the percent of visitors goes down
so it starts to give us kind of an
interesting proxy the cool thing is you
could do this with each state so I
looked at people from New Jersey and
they're typically coming in to kind of
Midtown to work people from Connecticut
are coming in from the north and my
favorite is people from California
because they only seem to get tickets in
the hippest New York Nate in brooklyn
neighborhoods of a Williamsburg and
Greenpoint you could actually see it in
the data you can quantify how cool
Californians are and these are really
like you know these are the core cool
neighborhoods of New York you can see it
in parking ticket data which is which is
pretty cool um I'm also believer of
exploring things that you you understand
not just kind of not just taking
something random there are some data I
sometimes see these cattle competitions
where they give you just a bunch of
features and they're like this is
feature 1 2 3 4 5 10 you have to predict
this and like that you don't you have no
context those driving me nuts and I
think having an understanding of what
you're doing adds a lot of value and I
keep that in mind as I do stuff in New
York too because sometimes i'm following
kind of intuitions that have one of my
favorites is i was walking through a
union square and i don't know if you've
ever seen these fast-food restaurants
that are combined so sometimes there's a
Taco Bell sometimes there's a pizza hut
but I'm have you ever seen that taco
bell pizza hut's right they exists out
there and and Papa John's like you know
they have these combinations and I was
taken to myself these combinations look
a little bit less cleaning them than the
regular ones just you know from instinct
so I went into the new york city health
inspection data and i took every paired
restaurant and compared them to the
individual restaurants with the average
health inspection scores higher is worse
and and found actually in fact that like
for example all the way in left you see
dunkin donuts on the left and blue
Baskin and Robbins and the right and the
combination was worse and in fact every
combination restaurant did worse the
most extreme was Papa John's with an 18
subway with 15 and then Papa John's
Subway's with a 28 and these are like
violation points adding one and two
violations these are averages so we're
starting to actually quantify these
these instincts you have walking around
New York I also out of curiosity ranked
all the fast food restaurants in New
York from cleanest the dirtiest in a
while I was in there is fun and found
out that white castle was the cleanest
which is pretty crazy and poor I hop was
was
scored the worst there everything
between the a and the B would be would
be a comprar vigil is better if it would
be a B score in New York on average and
so most of them aren't doing that well
it was funny is that white castle
responded to this news when it when it
made the press and one of the one of
their vice president said what what one
it I think very progressive statement
but white castle is president Richards
and said he wasn't surprised that chain
led to the pact if you've got time to
lean you got time to clean I was like I
don't want to work there that sound that
sounds rough ihop was like yeah we had
our problems a while ago we fixed it his
data had five year you know his data was
looking at five years if you only looked
at two years we do find that was ihop
statement which I also thought was
pretty funny and so let's say you do all
this in the end you know your goal is to
is to make make an impact with data and
part of that is getting your story out
and explaining in a way that people can
understand and that's so important right
and as we heard in Prior talks there are
lots of ways to measure your impact one
thing I've looked is looking for ways to
kind of prod the city to start to change
city life in New York and they make up
little things so for example if you've
ever ridden the New York City subway
system you're greeted with this
beautiful machine where they asked that
you go to buy a metrocard which is our
subway fare system and they say how much
do you want to spend on this card how
much want to put on you I put nine
dollars 19 or 39 this is from last year
now rides are 250 and the thing is when
you buy these things you also get a I
forget what the percentage of the time
but I think it's a five percent bonus so
you say I want a nine dollars but you
really pay nine dollars then you get
nine dollars and like 45 cents right so
there's these bonuses these amounts and
the weird thing is i did a proof and i'd
always ride the subway and I never had
zero balance I use these buttons I was
like what's going on so I did a
mathematical proof showing that you can
never get a zero balance using their
buttons and riding the subway that it
was like mathematically impossible and
when they expire the MTA was taking in
tens of millions dollars a year in
credit left over on Metro cards so you
know so I wrote about this and I don't
know if they were thrilled but the MTA
responded and they said these machines
do not hold an infinite amount of change
denominators are suggested to ensure
there's ample change to accommodate
customers who pay with cash that being
said we will certainly look at this as
part of the process involved in rolling
out the next scheduled fare increase
thank you so much until they got me
there they got me there
so the fare increase comes and I'm like
all right you know I don't hear anything
what's going to happen so I go to the
Machine and something really cool
happened they added a new button for me
there used to be by the way this is 919
in 39 because there's a one dollar fee
on your first card so it's a ten-dollar
bill 2005 now there's just random 1 2725
if you hit 2725 I think you get exactly
11 rides and no more so they've added a
little button there to make an even
number for me I think which is cool the
weird thing is that where else in the
world do you go in somewhere and be like
hi I have four dollars to spend you know
give me some apples like that's you know
you say I want to apples how much is the
cost you cannot go into New York City
sub which I would like to ride the train
three times how much will that be
today's of this day that is not the way
the New York City subway system it's
unbelievable instead it's like here's
amount of money thank you here's a
random out of money a good luck that is
where we are today so I'm not appeased
by this button but I'm pretty excited
that I got a button added to the
learning machine using using some math
um here's a speaking of the health
inspection scores this is a distribution
of scores in New York City and what
happens is all of our restaurants get a
B and C grades depending on how many
violations these violations are one or
two points you know you don't have a
temperature set correctly in the fridge
your sink is too close to the soap your
do knows all sorts of problems and if
you look 13 is the most you can get it
still get an A and as soon as you go to
14 you got to be so now you think that
the histogram of counts would be
somewhat even 13 14 same right
absolutely not what we're seeing is all
this bunching on the boundary of a and B
right so why is that happening right the
inspectors are in a little bit of Great
Inflation right yeah you're a 30 I
didn't see that cockroach I didn't say
like a good there's something very weird
happening here and here in the city now
unfortunately I can't look at which
inspectors doing this because they don't
release the inspector name in the open
data set but there's certainly something
funny going on you can see it in between
B and C as well it's very puzzling I
wrote about this and the Department of
Health responded with this gem
inspectors are not instructed to offer
leniency just a slight what they see the
final score is based on the extent of
the violations the inspector observes
Thank You Department of Health and I
guess I'll check that again in a few
years and see if they made any changes
in response I don't know it's a bit of a
black hole and I also noticed looking at
taxi fare data that New York City cabs
when you ride in them give or take a cab
and you pay with credit card at the
arienne they say hey would you like the
tip twenty twenty-five or thirty percent
all right and you know most people are
in fact more than half people hit one of
those buttons I think it's sixty percent
hit the twenty percent button and but no
one ever stop to think with twenty
percent of what they were stopping what
are you paying terms and on right it's
kind of like when you're at a restaurant
do they add tax so I was doing some
analysis and I realized that half the
cabs in New York we had two vendors one
called creative mobile technologies and
one verifone their two contracts one was
charging twenty percent on top of tolls
and taxes and the fair and the surcharge
the other one was only doing it on top
of the fair and surcharge so depending
on the brand of the computer in the back
of that cab you'd be tipping more
dependent and like as if a consumer
should know that right I didn't math it
was three to four hundred dollars more
year in salary for the drivers of the
creative mobile technology cabs and the
verifone calves right which is crazy and
such a highly regulated industry in New
York everything is regularly down to the
exact queue of the color and everything
and so when I wrote about that the taxi
Limousine Commission responded we
appreciate that work than Windows
analysis and we're giving it a thorough
read on but sure enough a few weeks
later in fact they did reprogram half
the cabs in New York it didn't go
exactly as I planned they made half of
them more expensive so now all cabs in
New York will tip on top of tools but at
least it's fair I think what happened is
that the these systems are done by the
vendors and then and then the taxi
driver is not going to you know they're
all going to go for the better one right
make more money so the other one had to
kind of you know I kind of caused this
this ship but i do feel good that it's a
little bit more transparent now you
don't think choice um a few more
examples this is by the way at the back
of every new york city police car over
the last few months we now have twitter
handles it's crazy every precinct now
has a twitter handle and so they're
starting to use twitter which is great
they do things like this the 5th
precinct had a hundred and fifteen
percent increase and bicycle closures
this year police officers will be
enforcing violations by bicyclist
hashtag bike space safety which is cool
and I'm sitting there looking at this on
like 115 percent increase in bicycle
collisions that's pretty dramatic like
it must be total carnage like one day
it's fine my god so but with open data
we can start to actually ask these
questions this is so cool by the way
haven't challenging journalists as well
when they write stories to release their
raw data so we can all check it's really
cool when you get to start looking what
journalists
same with the city show your work right
where did this come from so I wrote
about that and the New York Police
Department said no they didn't say
anything for sure we never got to the
bottom of that and and one last example
it was was exploring fire hydrants in
New York so I mapped hydrants but these
aren't just any hydrants these are the
top 250 revenue grossing hydrants in
terms of parking ticket revenue so when
cars get within 50 feet of enemies
hydrants they ticket right there like a
little like venus fly and and if you map
the hydrants you can see the upper east
side of manhattan is like crazy they
just love ticketing for prior items i
don't know that precinct probably gets a
lot more revenue but what was more
fascinating and mapping these hydros by
the way this is just an aggregation
right like aggregate kent and these
stories just pop out on you a great
things when you a great something you
look for an outlier and there's a story
when you start looking at municipal data
there's usually a story and in this case
i found these two hydrants and the in
the lower east side that were together
are making over 55,000 dollars a year
just being hydrants just standing there
hydrants more than minimum wage just
being hydrants it's fascinating and and
you know you start to look at this and
this isn't you know something that has
been happening for 56 years the revenue
is quite substantial and if you i went
on to when i checked out this fun what
you see is that there's a hydrant and
then what looks like a bike lane and in
new york where these separated bike
lanes where you have you have you have
the curb then a bike lane then the cars
park and then the street so that way the
car parked cars so it's kind of one of
those deals except technically it turns
out it wasn't a bike lane it was called
the curb extension which meant is like a
sidewalk extension which you would never
know because they're cyclists on it all
day but you were supposed to know that
the Department of Transportation painted
this lovely parking spots for cars to
park there and your Police Department
disagreed with this designation and this
went on for years by the way the google
street view car drove by and caught this
parking ticket on the gods windshield
which I appreciated that that was caught
on google maps and there was actually a
sign in Chinese your chinatown on the
Hydran hanging on a hanger they said do
not park here but it was only in Chinese
so I wrote about that and the
departmentation said well we have not
received any complaints about this
location will review the roadway
markings and make any appropriate
alterations nice Eric I only know we'll
see what happens there and amazingly
enough three weeks later they came when
they repainted the streets just from
these small data de strawberries right
hyperlocal this is what open data allows
I don't expect them
sit and do this kind of work they
probably have a lot going on you know
keeping the city running but you know
when you start to make observations
locally with open data and a little bit
of data science a little you know even
simple things like aggregating you can
start to tell stories and really make
change happen because it's no longer
you're not just a crazy person
complaining you're crazy person
complaining with data which is way
better you got farther and and so I've
learned you know look in the end to make
these changes I find that important you
want to connect with people know your
audience right keep simplicity is okay
there are things that need to be complex
but there's but don't always be scared
away by the fact that everything is to
be so complex some problems call for it
others you can do really good things
just with descriptive statistics simple
stuff and start to really tight take
apart the stories hidden within data and
I'll point out that you know for I know
that this is the data comes from many of
you probably have a lot of experience
but this is just to give you an idea of
the type stuff that can be done very
quickly now with open data this is a
view of traffic collisions in New York
from the open data portal and in my
second class with my urban planning
students one who's another nominee
program experience was able to use Excel
and start to map out the way injuries
are caused around the zip code around
our University in a second class just
using Excel right using like pivot
tables and other stuff stuff so this is
not rocket is it not rocket science is
really valuable stuff for all of us not
just for could program errs and
something like this which is graffiti
complaints even a high schooler in
something called City term which was a
high school visiting program in New York
made this map without any computer
skills drawing graffiti so you can
really you can really kind of take data
and run with it so I guess in the end
I'd say anyone can be a data storyteller
if they know how and if you're
interested in following you know my
antics around around New York and
working with agencies and really
advocating for the release and less PDFs
more more raw data around New York City
check out I quant New York where I post
and have a mailing list and thank you so
much i'll open up the questions